ηθυσία να δοκιμάσουμε κάτι καινούργιο έχουμε που χτήσει τοε πιδήτττο έκανε ο κόσμος ς εύρω
εκλογέςτο έκανε να θα το δούμε ημα θα το δούμε ακόμη περισσότερο νιόω ότι ο
κόσμος και με τα προβλήματα που έχουμε επί προηγουμένος θεματις ακρίβγιας μιώθει από μονομένος από
την πολιτική γιεσία έχει δηλαδή δεν σεύεται αλλά και ούτε εμπιστεύεται την πολιτική εσία παλιότερα
είταν και ταμπού δηλαδήσουν να κοντά στο κόμμασ ότι ελεγετο κόμμασου το έκανες αυτή στιγμή
είναι πολύ διαφορετικό έχει το θεδικό κομμάτι ότι ο κόσμος πέπει να σκέφτεται ιο αν
εξάρτητα εγώ είμαι υπέρ να σκεφτεικόσμος αν εξαρτέ από την άλλι όμως θα πρέπιους καιμβίνους
βεβαίως έχει οη κινδύνου και βεβαίως δεν μπορούμε από το ένα ακρο να πάμε στο
άλλο ακρο χρειάζεται μια όριμότητα που δεν υπάρχει υτή τη στιγμή θεωρώ ότι ι επόμενες
εκλογές το κός ιικ ιξι θα είναι σ αυτό το το μίγμα δηλαδή της αντίδρασης
ψύως αντίδρασης παρά ψήφο θετική ψύβος υπερκαποικόμματος γιατί δεν υποηρερισότεται επιστεπουν σε κανέναν δεν επιστεύουστα
κόμματα δεν πιστεύουν στα άτομα τουλάχιστο θέλουν να δοκιμάσουν κάτι διαφορετικό αι νομίζω θα πάρει
κάποιο χρωνικό διάστημα μέχρι να ιρεμίσουμε να οριμάσουμε στα παλι να έρθουμε πίσω όχι στα
παγιά αλλά τουλάχιστο να είμαστε πιο δομημένοι στον τρόπο αποφάσις επιστε εώ ότι κάποιου ψύπησαν
στις θευροκλοκές ένα πράγμα θα ψηπίζουν κάτι πολύ διαφορεικόστες βουλευτικές και οο κομμάτικός χάρτης θα
αλλάξει θέλοντας και μείτώρα οι ευρώπη θεωρίς ότι μπορεί να βάλει ένα φρένο ψε όλα
αυτά κάνειο των ανρά είναι σε θέση ναβαλει έναφρόχι γιατί ι διαιευρώπι δεν ξέρε τι
θέλει είναι πολλές οι φωνές διαφορετικές οι φωνές βλέπουμε μια σημαντική ανοδώ τις ακροδεξιάς δηλαδή
και πάλι είναι ας ψήφος αντίδρασης σε μεγάλο βαθμό υπάρχουν αρκετές χώρες που ασπάζονται αυτά
που λέει των ατρά όχι ι παραδοσιακές χώρες αλλά βλέπουμε χώρες που προς τα εκεί
κοινούνται την ίδια στιγμή